alice was not the child her mother
expected
claudia was three months pregnant when
doctors told her she was infected with
the zika virus and that her
unborn daughter would suffer from
lifelong disabilities
realizing that alice will never have a
childhood like other kids
her heart sank but four years on claudia
says
the disability turned out to be a
blessing
she's loved by her neighbors the family
and most of all by
children who seem to be able to
communicate with her better than i can
and she wants to play with them but
sometimes her disability gets in the way
she has convulsions her muscles are weak
she can't sit properly
alice is born with what doctors call
microcephaly her brain is failing to
develop fully it's a consequence of her
mother being infected with
the zika virus through a mosquito bite
during her pregnancy
there are no vaccines nor cure for the
virus that spreads through mosquitoes
and sexual contact
in 2016 the world health organization
declared zika a public health emergency
of international concern
the outbreak started in brazil spreading
to cape verde as a result of the
epidemic more than 3
700 babies worldwide were born with
birth defects
at the time countries issued travel
warnings
including asking citizens to delay
pregnancies there was this fear that
zika
would spread from the islands of cape
verde to
the rest of africa onto the rest of the
world
but that did not happen the virus
suddenly disappeared just like it
appeared
dr george noel barreto from the
country's health ministry believes zika
ran its course
infected a large portion of the
population and herd immunity developed
halting the spread still he fears zika
is lurking in the capital's drainage
system
that's a breeding ground for mosquitoes
saying there could be another outbreak
the immunity can be lost as the years
pass we believe people can be
also can be again
unprotected and can be infected again
surveillance of infected zika children
has stalled due to the covid pandemic
and mothers fear bringing their children
to hospital
children with cerebral palsy need
continuous physical therapy and good
nutrition
support and commitment of parents makes
a lot of difference
because of the pandemic claudia 2 has
been avoiding hospitals
when alice is in pain or has convulsions
[Music]
she plays a song to her that she would
listen to
when she was pregnant to soothe her
daughter's pain
nicholas hawk al-jazeera praia